what's also worse than we could have
ever imagined is the degree to which
Donald Trump and people around him are
desperate to endanger the life really
the lives not only of the Ukraine
whistleblower but of the whistleblowers
family as well now I told you at the
start of the Ukraine whistleblower
Fiasco that Donald Trump and his
acolytes will not stop until the
whistleblower is in danger and it
actually is starting to seem like they
will not stop until the whistleblower
potentially loses their life
Trump has already referred to the
whistleblower as a spy as a traitor
we know that Trump is working very very
hard to leak the name of the
whistleblower despite whistleblower
protection being a core tenet of the
United States Trump did one of his magus
safeSpace rallies last night in
Lexington Kentucky Lexington Kentucky
rather the home state of totally toxic
ophthalmologist Senator Rand Paul and
Rand Paul an advocate for privacy an
advocate for the rule of law an advocate
for the Constitution Rand Paul claiming
that they have the whistleblowers name
and the crowd goes wild and imploring
imploring the media to out the
whistleblower printing their name
they're not going to stop until the
whistleblower may be dead take a look
President Trump has great courage he
faces down the fake media every day
but Congress needs to step up and have
equal courage to defend the president
Hunter Biden made $50,000 a month that's
the definition of corruption we know he
got it only because of his family
connections we also now know the name of
the whistleblower
the whistleblower needs to come before
Congress as a material witness because
he worked for Joe Biden at the same time
hunter Biden was getting money from
corrupt oligarchs I say tonight to the
media do your job and print his name
[Music]
the crowd cheers that they know the name
of the whistleblower they want him outed
which will of course immediately
endanger not only the life of the
whistleblower but of their family as
well this is the type of thing
that Trump brown nosers like Rand Paul
do when they're on good terms with Trump
but then sometimes those relationships
with Donald Trump go bad and Trump
abandons them they have a falling out
and later they'll say yeah maybe that
was a mistake I don't stand behind
everything I did in support of Trump and
when it comes to Rand Paul it's
particularly hypocritical because Rand
Paul again has been touting his entire
political career he's all about the
Constitution he's all about the
framework that was established in the
United States of America around privacy
rights this has been his entire career
and here is Rand Paul privacy advocate
Rand Paul rule of law advocate Rand Paul
talking about let's violate the
framework upon which our country is
based in violation of the whistleblowers
privacy rights for his political gain to
ingratiate himself with Donald Trump who
he's been golfing with regularly another
touch by the way I don't know if you
were listening you didn't see this if
you watched that clip we just played
they gave the trumpet standing on the
stage behind Trump t-shirts that say
read the transcript which is Trump's
continued reference to the idea that if
you just look at the transcript it
completely vindicates Donald Trump of
any wrongdoing now of course they didn't
release a transcript of the phone call
they released what seemed to be about
seven or eight minutes of conversation
from a phone call that we know lasted a
half hour which is by the way
extraordinarily incriminating of Trump
Trump is not a cognitively strong enough
to recognize that the trance quote
transcript even the small pieces of it
that were published does not vindicate
Trump its incriminating but they gave
everybody on stage and shirts that say
release that read the transcript now
what they are asking for here in terms
of media go ahead and out the
whistleblower this runs counter to the
law now you can feel that politically
the whistleblower should be outed you
might take that position as a political
position but the whistleblower is
protected by law and Donald
Trump and Rand Paul claimed to be about
law and order and law and order says
that the whistleblowers identity must be
protected so they're all jumping on this
messaging here is Donald Trump two days
ago saying the same thing exposed the
whistleblower which any reasonable
person interprets as instantly
endangering the life of the
whistleblower
well the whistleblower gave a very
inaccurate report and as you know
certain of the media released
information about a man that they said
was the whistleblower I don't know if
that's true or not but what they said is
he's an Obama person it was involved
with Brennan Susan Rice which means
Obama but he was like a big a big anti
Trump person hated Trump and they said
terrible things now I don't know if it's
true or not but that was reported by
some of the media so you'll have to find
out I don't know why the media is not on
it because the whistleblower gave a very
inaccurate report about my phone call my
phone call was perfecta it was totally
appropriate but he gave a report he or
she but according to the newspapers it's
a he they think they know they know who
it is you know who it is you just don't
want to report it
CNN knows who it is but you don't want
to report it the wit and you know you'd
be doing the public the service if you
did the whistleblower gave a false
report and because of that false report
people thought bad things were done and
then you had chip go out and speak
before Congress and before the American
people and give a false story he made up
a story and then I released after II
after all this was done I released and
everybody said he didn't do anything
wrong but the whistleblower should be
this is an incitement of violence
against the whistleblower I mean listen
you can say Trump is not personally
saying attack the whistleblower but it
is in practice an incitement of violence
against the whistleblower because
they're being exposed immediately in
dangers their life it's also
increasingly irrelevant though okay and
let me explain this to you
we have Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN
Minh we have according to the spectator
which I talked about earlier today seven
new whistleblowers we have Donald
Trump's partial transcript itself which
is massively incriminating
so the initial whistleblower becomes
less and less relevant every time that
their claims are corroborated think
about when someone calls the police and
reports a burglary or a crime of some
kind
and they want anonymity but the police
show up and they investigate and they
find other witnesses that saw the same
thing they find evidence that
corroborates that initial anonymous
report it no longer matters who
originally made that first anonymous
report the whistleblower that Donald
Trump wants outed is increasingly
irrelevant as we have witnesses who were
in the room who heard the July 25 phone
call between Trump and Ukrainian
president Solinsky
we have Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN
Minh so Trump is doing what he does best
it's really the only thing he can do
which is deflect the blame try to
distract the media make the story an
adjudication of the initial
whistleblower and you know that this is
not going well because whenever you hear
others come to Trump's defense like Rand
Paul in this case they don't defend
Trump's actions because Trump's actions
are not defensible they attack the
whistleblower they go to the media and
there's another important element here
that we have to consider by doing this
they are also intimidating future
potential whistleblowers and I've said
this before when you make a big show of
publicly calling for the outing of a
whistleblower you are sending a message
to others who know things that says if
you come forward we will publicly on the
national stage try to out you and your
life will be at risk and the life of
your family will be at risk
SiC its anti-american and we can't allow
them to get away with it we really can't
I believe that the fastest recourse the
world were a year from the election it's
just 12 months and then we can end this
national nightmare of what will have
been a four-year nightmare I believe
that that is still the fastest path make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram for more of this story
and others at david pakman show give us
a follow and while you're there follow
me on instagram at david pakman as well